okay this next question comes from bill
yates it's a live question it says i
have a fantasia so it means that one
lacks a mind's eye lacks inner sound
feeling and even hearing how does lou
and you sean as well think the
phenomenon would interact with someone
such as himself
such as billiate
i would say perhaps even more intimately
we don't know because people who suffer
from that also sometimes have other
abilities that we don't really have
because they have a
heightened sense in other areas
um we know that there are people for
example who are blind and they can
echolocate they can actually use sound
to to have in their minds eye and
understanding of the environment around
them now that seems kind of crazy for us
and yet we see it in nature all the time
whether it's dolphins or bats or
anything else
um
you know there are people who who are
certainly
suffer from for example um
autism extreme for some forms of
multitasking and yet
they have photographic memory they can
do incredible extreme mathematical
computations in their head they can
they're they're they're piano uh
virtuosos right and have never never had
any formal training in it how is that
possible well it's possible because the
human brain um is first of all it's
wonderfully equipped and it's an
incredible organ
but it's it's it's it's still very
little understood about the human brain
and
um you know some sometimes there's an
old i'll answer your question but maybe
a little bit more succinctly um
there was a uh a young student uh who
was trying to learn from the master and
the master says do you do you now see
young students says no master i've been
looking for months and months and months
at the sunset you've been telling me to
look at
near the mount over the mountain and i
and i i still don't see
and the master says to the student
in order to see sometimes you have to
close your eyes
and uh
you know
there you go right sometimes
sometimes you can actually see more
clearly by closing your eyes and you can
see with your eyes open in other words
we have preconceptions that could be
removed and then that would give us a
greater understanding or insight
yeah i mean sometimes our you know
sometimes our sense is foolish look at
an optical illusion right an optical
illusion is just that where our eyes are
telling us one thing but reality is
something different right and in this
case our senses are failing us not all
senses are necessarily beneficial and
they can be fooled they can be spoofed
right
human vision is just another sensor
collection system like hearing and
touching and tasting and whatnot
and and we know they can be spoofed our
feelings can be spoofed right you can
betrayed by by someone our site can be
spooked you have optical illusions our
hearing can be spoofed uh you know we're
not perfect systems we we we they can be
flawed and sometimes
filtering out certain inputs certain
data can actually be beneficial perhaps
sorry john i kept interrupting you
oh no man that's okay um interestingly
enough without an official diagnosis i
believe i suffer from a fantasia as well
i don't possess a very
vibrant inner mind's eye
except upon waking from dreams or
frankly very vivid trance states
where i've taken myself down through
meditation to a
a different place um
for me that was
finding out that the word a fantasia
existed to me was very important to
understanding myself and my mind's eye
and what my personal
inter
inner experience is
that led to researching things like
interoception
understanding the inner workings of the
body and the perception of the inner
workings of your body
something you can do through meditation
is to actually start to pinpoint certain
places of the body and then start to
understand their processes
but beyond that i put
because of
things i've witnessed and experienced
and i'm very lucky to have witnessed and
experienced some things in the company
of others
um especially some of the
the harder to accept things that maybe
somebody people would uh consider excuse
me consider like poltergeist activity or
things like that i've been lucky enough
to have other witnesses with me to at
least
say that we saw that thing we may not
know why or what but that led me to
research periphrania
and peripherania is like having
schizophrenia without the bad parts
and i did i did a great deal of
searching you know down the co-morbidity
of those things and
i find it very interesting that the
phenomenon interacts with human
consciousness in a way that can mirror
mental illness
it can and it seems that some of some
unknown if
one perseverates on these ideas without
finding validity or answers that it may
be one of those triggers for mental
illness now whether those are parts of
our fundamental archetype
of our consciousness or not or whether
that that's directly due to the
phenomenon or not i can't say
i think all of us has to take the time
to go
what's up with me what's my list of
things going on with me what can i
change what can i understand
and
and how can i be the most
effective human being while observing my
own life
i don't know if that makes sense i don't
know a lot of people that are interested
in living their life in real time
if that makes sense
a lot of folks are looking to jump from
one dopamine fix to another
fear avoidance risk avoidance and
pleasure seeking and a lot of people
would say that that in itself is the
human condition and i don't want to say
that i'm holier than now or better than
anybody just because i want to check out
the societal aspect of a lot of things
and delve deeper into what what a lot of
us call the matrix
you know casually
um
but i think that that's where many of
the answers to this are gonna are gonna
lie for a lot of people
we were talking off-air lou and sean
and myself about how
how uncomfortable it is at least for
myself and many others judging by the
comments it can be to study this
phenomenon and just consciousness in
general and how that's something that
almost no one talks about i have an
episode with carl firsten who is a
neuroscientist one of the if not the
most cited neuroscientist just on this
on how destabilizing and debilitating
can be i'm still recovering from
well i
you if you want you can watch that
episode people who are interested by the
way i consider it to be the most
important episode of all the theories of
everything podcasts because it sets the
stage and talks about something that you
may feel extremely uncomfortable with
and think that you're alone but you're
not and you may think that is hopeless
but it's not